So while you guys were gone,
I went on Wikipedia and looked up,
oh,
cyrus,
you know,
because when I did the research for this
book certainly wasn't possible to get
access to that kind of information,
instantaneous,
you know,
and the stories that are laid out in
there,
there's a thread that runs through the
stories that's laid out there that's
quite similar to the one that I told
you,
but there's all sorts of details that
are very radically different.
And so I don't really know what to say
about that.
And you know,
part of the reason that people like
Joseph Campbell and Carl young and,
uh,
the ridge,
there was an original anthropologist and
armchair anthropologist who wrote a book
called the Golden Bough,
whose name escapes me momentarily,
but it was one of the first attempts to
do across cultural categorization of
mythology and to look for underlying
commonalities.
Now,
the problem is,
you know,
I told you about Naomi Klein going down
to Argentina and looking at the factory
through her particular Lens.
The problem is is that when you develop
a lens and then you look at things
through it,
you may just see what that lends
heightens,
you know,
and I think that that's a criticism that
could be leveled against the sorts of
things that I'm telling you about that
I've cherry picked certain stories and
interpreted them in certain ways so that
they fall coherently into a,
a scheme of thought and so I'll tell you
some of the things that I do
methodologically to protect myself
against that in so far as that's
possible.
So
there's this idea in psychology called
the multi-method multi multitrack method
of construct validation,
which is God awful agglomeration of,
of a jargon,
but it actually means something and it
was the construction of two
psychologists back in the late 19
fifties crime back in meal who are
interested in what psychologists meant
when they said something exists,
like say anger.
Is that a real thing?
Well,
what do you mean?
What do you mean thing?
What is it that you're talking about?
What?
His anger exactly.
I don't mean as anger,
but as an idea what sort of idea is the
idea of anger or the idea of anxiety or
the idea of sadness or the idea of self
esteem or self competence or any of
these things that psychologists talk
about as if their realities.
It's like,
well,
some realities are very tangible,
right?
And and it's,
it's somewhat easy to come to agreement
about the contours of their existence in
the borders,
but other things are way more difficult
than that.
And so their idea was that if something
actually exists that you should be able
to measure it multiple ways using
multiple techniques and still get the
same answer.
And so your senses do that.
You have five of them.
The reason you have five apparently is
because evolution has determined that if
you only had four or you die more often,
you know,
so it seems as if you have five separate
sources of information that all lead to
the same conclusion.
You can be relatively certain that the
conclusion that's reached is real.
Okay.
Well,
the multimap multitrack method is,
is an application of that idea to
construct validation,
which is like you can think of anger as
an idea,
as a construct.
It's a terminological issue.
Just define it as a construct.
Psychological Constructs.
How do you know if they're real?
Well,
the idea is it's very complicated.
You have to measure them in multiple
ways.
All the ways you measure them have to
give the same reading.
Then you have to show that that idea is
the same in certain ways as other ideas
that it's related to and different from
other ideas that it's not related to.
So let me give you an example.
There's a construct neuroticism,
and you might say,
well,
there's another construct depression.
Well then you might say,
well,
are those separate?
Are they the same?
Well,
that's a tough one because in many,
many ways they're the same.
Are they the same in any important?
Are they different in any important
ways?
Well,
the way you do that technically is you
would measure neuroticism,
however you were going to measure it.
Maybe I'd have you tell me how neurotic
you were using a questionnaire and then
I'd have your friend tell me and maybe
you're a parent,
so we got it pretty good triangulation
on your neuroticism,
and then I'd have them do the same
thing.
All of those people do the same thing
with regards to your levels of
depression and anxiety.
Then I'd use both those measures to
predict something else like how well
your life goes in terms of career over
the next 10 years and if neuroticism
predicted and depression predicted so
they were correlated,
then I think,
well there's some relationship and then
I'd look at them at the same time.
If I predict with neuroticism and then I
add new depression to the mixed,
does that give me more predictive power?
It's sort of like is does a equals C or
does a plus b?
We'll see.
That's all you're asking your regression
equation,
roughly speaking.
Well,
if a equals c is just as good as a plus
b equals c,
then one of the things,
especially if the two things are also
correlated,
depression and anxiety and neuroticism
are going to be very highly correlated.
Like point seven,
something like that.
You might say,
well those are the same thing just
because they have different names.
It's not helpful.
So.
And part of it is,
you know,
it's a pragmatic conceptualize.
A Asian of reality is like,
is this,
is this categorization structure good
for something?
Okay,
well,
so anyways,
all unpack all that and say,
well part of my rules for determining
whether these things were useful or not
was to see if the idea is applied across
multiple levels of analysis.
So that's why I told you about the
conceptual.
So sort of the cognitive psychology and
then the neuropsychological.
So there's some,
you know,
input of brain research and then the
narrative or mythological and then the
cross cultural.
I think,
well,
those all stack up in a certain way so
that if you look between all of them,
you can see a pattern and it seems to me
increasingly unlikely that that pattern
would be there across all of those
levels at the same time.
Now you could say,
well,
you know,
that depends on how good you are at
weaving a story,
but at some point
encapsulating that many phenomena and
weaving a coherent story out of them.
If such a thing doesn't exist,
it seems to be to become cognitively
impossible.
You just can't do it unless there's
actually something there.
So and every,
you know,
of course,
everything I tell you also,
is there a simplification?
It has to be because you could spend
your whole life investigating any of the
things that we're talking about.
And so what I'm hoping is that I've
abstracted out the central issues of
these multiple levels of analysis and
that,
you know,
put together each of them support all
the others anyways.
Who knows,
you know,
I don't know,
but
so far so good.
Okay.
So this is a cool representation.
I really liked this one.
This is called the open virgin and it's
a 14th or 13th century sculpture,
if I remember correctly.
It's made out of wood and these things
were actually.
This isn't the only one of them.
They were a form of religious
representation that that had different
exemplars.
You could find different ones of them
online.
This is brilliant,
this bloody thing as far as I'm
concerned,
so let me show you.
Let me show you this,
this figure again,
so basically what you have here in this
figure,
this is at world conception and the
world conception is roughly.
There's an individual positive and
negative.
He's he or she is in a cultural sphere
that's positive or negative,
that's embedded in the world outside of
culture that's positive and negative and
all of it comes from potential.
That's the idea.
Now,
this map shows all of the positives and
negatives in relationship to one
another.
You see it's not perfectly symmetrical
and the reason for that is as far as I
can tell,
the adversarial element of the
individual is the thing that generates
the tyrannical element of culture and
that's the thing that like gets in your
way of establishing a creation,
creative relationship with what you
don't know.
Well anyways,
here's,
here is a manifestation of that.
I believe,
and I liked this manifestation because
like it's obviously Christian but not.
It's more mythological than Christian
and the reason for that,
well it's quite obvious.
So the,
the super ordinate figure is married.
The feminine now you think,
well it's amazing the person who carved
this just didn't get burnt up at the
inquisition because it's a radical idea,
but it's,
it's just an indication of how the
mythology can change the causal
relationship between these different
elements.
So you have Mary there,
she's sort of,
she's the ultimate in femininity,
a ultimate feminine Deity,
but only the positive side.
Right?
And then within her.
So it's like nature opens itself up and
benevolent nature opens itself up and
what you see inside is culture.
That's God the father holding the
individual.
And the individual in this case is the
crucified Christ,
which is a wonderful conceptualization
as far as I'm concerned,
because of course that is what life does
to people.
That's why that's such a powerful
symbol.
It's like,
you know,
Christ is the person who has to face the
reality of his own death voluntarily or
involuntarily who's betrayed by his
culture and betrayed by his friends.
It's like,
it's,
it's sort of like he's,
he's exposed to the most,
the most torturous elements of
individual Ba and simultaneously,
at least in principle,
transcends them while you bloody well
better do that because otherwise,
well,
what's going to happen?
You're just,
you're done.
If you don't do that,
and it's even worse.
It's not only that you fail,
that's just the beginnings of it.
If you can't transcend the tragedy of
your being,
then you get corrupted.
You know,
because I see this happening to people
all the time.
So
you know,
if you're suffering and you can't cope
with it,
generally speaking,
what happens is that it embitters you.
And once you get bitter,
you get resentful.
And once you get resentful,
you look for revenge.
And that can just get completely out of
hand.
Now that's a quick trip to the worst
suburb of the underworld,
that's for sure.
So,
you know,
it's not only that if you don't manage
this transcendent act that you're
swamped by the tragedy of your life,
it's worse than that.
You're swamped by the tragedy of your
life.
And then that corrupts you.
And then you start working to make
everything even more tragic than it has
to be.
And so I think that's why,
you know,
in medieval Christian conceptualizations
in particular,
that the idea of hell,
the desk,
that the idea that you were destined to
hell was worse than the idea of dying.
And that's a strange idea,
you know,
because you think this is what the
terror management theorists thing too is
like,
oh,
there's nothing worse than the fear of
death.
It's,
that's wrong.
They don't have the right imagination.
There are lots of things that are worse
than the fear of death.
So
I'm not trying to trivialize the fear of
death,
obviously,
you know,
but,
but I don't think it's very difficult
to,
to understand that there are some things
that you would rather die than do.
I mean,
I'm sure that I could get you guys to
sit for 15 minutes and say,
okay,
you list 10 things that you would rather
die than do.
Oh,
that's easy.
That's easy.
Especially if you're a parent,
you can think of those things in no time
flat.
Okay.
So that was pretty interesting.
So you've got the superordinate feminine
figure here,
which is not what you'd expect from a
Christian representation,
right?
You expect God to be on the outside and
then Mary and then Christ in all
likelihood.
Although that would also be a valid
representation.
Right?
So because you can think of the mother
as something that's protected by the
culture and supporting the individual
because that's basically what this
representation shows.
But then you see on the,
on the open side,
so I really liked this.
I think it's so cool is that you've got
all these people who aren't archetipal
figures there in the little crowd and
they're gazing at the central figure and
of course that's exactly what's happened
in Christianity for 2000 years.
Right?
And so far spread is that for 2000 years
people have been looking at that image
which is the crucifixion transfixed by
it.
Well,
why?
you know,
for reasons that we don't understand,
when everybody woke up and like the late
18 hundreds and said,
why were we looking at that for the last
2000 years?
The first answer was,
well,
we really don't have the foggiest idea.
You know,
it was just one of the things that we
did,
roughly speaking,
it encapsulated people within the belief
system.
So that's another good example anyway,
of how this archetypal imagery can
manifest itself,
say spontaneously in the imagination of
an artist.
And the thing is the,
that's a sacred image and it,
it is.
In actuality that's what it is.
What it shows is while there's a
superordinate transcendent natural order
that's,
that has a beneficial element that we
associate with femininity and inside
that there is a supportive culture,
is properly nested if things are
organized properly and it's both of
those things that provide support for
the suffering.
Individuals like,
yeah,
that was pretty much gone it so now that
doesn't exhaust the meaning of this
particular representation.
There's a lot more to it than that,
but just that's not so bad.
And then you know,
I can show you a,
a more negative representation.
I think I've showed you this before,
like this would be a representation of
the negative element of the feminine.
And so you have Kelly here.
Kelly is the goddess to whom you make
sacrifices.
Hopefully if you make the right
sacrifices,
then Kelly turns into her positive
counterpart and you know,
you think,
well that's.
You know what?
Huh?
How does sacrifice effect your
relationship with the gods?
Well,
first of all,
there's no gods and second of all,
well then you know,
what the hell are you doing with the
sacrifices?
But it's pretty straightforward.
We've already talked about this at
length,
you do make sacrifices all the time and
what that means is that you act as if
you can have a relationship with your,
with being,
you assume that if you withhold certain
things from yourself now that you will
improve your relationship both with
nature and culture.
It's like,
and I already told you guys that as far
as I was concerned,
that was like the most stunning
cognitive discovery of mankind.
It's the discovery of the future and
it's the discovery of the relationship
between the present and the future.
You know,
it's,
it's such an amazing idea that you can
alter your behavior now and it'll pay
off any year.
God,
that's not obvious.
It's certainly not animals.
Don't think that way.
No,
I mean some of them act that way,
like these and so on,
but that's just built right into their
behavior as far as we could tell.
So anyway,
so there's Kelly,
you know,
she's a spider.
She's in a web of fire.
The fire is outside at web that's made
out of skulls.
She's got weapons in her hand.
Your hair is on fire.
She's got a headdress of skulls.
I mean if you ever saw something like
that,
it would traumatize you so badly.
You wouldn't be able to get out of your
house for like five years and that's
exactly what it is.
That's what it is.
It's a representation of all of that.
That would traumatize you if you
encountered it and they know it's an
attempt to encapsulate that as an image
and what you could say in some sense is
that the people who developed this
image,
we're attempting to conceptualize the
class of all terrifying things and once
you get the classical terrifying things
conceptualize,
you can come up with the class of all
useful responses and that would be
something like the proper way to behave
and sacrifices and integral element of
that.
It's like,
yeah,
absolutely right.
Absolutely dead on.
So unless you don't believe that
sacrifice works,
in which case,
what the hell are you doing here?
You know,
I mean you act out your belief.
So when it's a firm belief,
and you would also say if things fell
apart so badly that sacrifice,
no,
no longer paid off.
Your lights would basically become
intolerable,
so because it would mean you have,
you would have,
would have abandoned all sense of
control over the outcomes of your
actions while you.
You can't live like that.
You'd just die of stress so well.
And as I said,
you know,
she's,
she was pregnant.
She's given birth to this unfortunate
character who she's devouring intense
first,
like it's a rough image.
It's the image of the destructive
element of nature.
And so that's the negative side of the
feminine,
we might say,
so
mirrors that positive representation.
This is a Greek representation that's
Diana or Artemis hoping.
I'm remembering this properly.
She's multi breasted.
Know this circle around her head is
undoubtedly a representation of her
cosmic nature,
you know,
so it's like a halo.
The Halo is basically a planetary body
like the sudden,
do you call it cosmic body,
like the sun or the moon behind the head
of the divine individual with all of
that power,
you know,
shining forward.
So it's an attempt to use,
you know,
if you look up at the moon or you look
up at the sun,
there's an element of that that's
characterized by all.
You can't help but feel that at least
it's beauty and power and sometimes it's
overwhelming.
Well you,
you take the representation of the,
of the personality and you throw the
representation of these cosmic powers
behind it and it's an attempt to
represent transcendent value.
It's very intelligent,
brilliant.
In fact,
and so partly what you're trying to do
as you conduct your life is you're
trying to get all of these archetypal
forces in proper balance and I suppose
in some sense to get them tilted towards
the good.
If that's possible.
I mean that's what this.
That's what this representation in some
sense you might say,
where is it here?
Yeah.
You might say,
well,
if,
if you got everything ordered properly,
this is what being would be like
still pretty rough given that the
crucifix is at its center.
No,
no.
I don't know.
If you think about it from a purely
technical perspective,
roughly speaking,
each of these archetypes is split into
positive and negative.
You might say,
well,
that's just how it is.
There is no appropriate.
There is no way that you can interact
with all of them so that the whole
system tilts towards the positive.
No,
but
okay,
but I don't think that's true.
I think you can get them lined up so
that things tilt towards the positive
and I think that you can detect when
that happens because that those are the
periods in your life where you feel that
your richly enough engaged in what
you're doing in life is meaningful
enough so that the rest of it,
the substructure that makes it necessary
is,
is worth it.
It's worthwhile in all that the negative
exists is okay,
given the way that things are structured
now,
I think that whether or not that's true
is in some sense the eternal question of
mankind.
You know,
can you organize your life so that it's
good?
Well,
it seems like you can certainly allow
your life to degenerate so that it's
terrible.
That seems indisputable.
Right?
And there does seem to be an element of
choice in that,
although you know something terrible
could happen to you that you have no
choice,
you have no choice of or control over,
but it certainly seems that you could do
any number of stupid and blind things
that make everything worse.
I think that's a common experience and I
also think you'd be hard pressed to find
anyone who wouldn't say that there were
things they did consciously and
willingly that were up their own choice
that they didn't have to do that made
things worse.
So we seem to have some sense of our
moral agency and we seem automatically
to accept some responsibility for the
outcomes of our actions.
And so partly what that means is that we
do believe that we can make things
better or worse.
And I suppose in some way that means
that we believe we can tap the whole
architectural structure of being into
the positive,
into the positive.
Well,
I would say
no.
If you
drilled down to the bottom of
existentialism,
in some sense that's the question,
the existentialists pose know,
is there a manner of conducting your
life such that it becomes,
it's not merely acceptable,
it's more than that.
You'd say,
yes,
this is how it should be.
Well,
what we're going to do now,
although we're not going to do it today,
is we're going to start talking about
other representations of this
substructure from other religious
traditions and we're going to also talk
about ways that you might relate to
these figures.
You know,
because one question might be while
you're part of your culture and it's got
an orderly element and a protective
element and a tear radical element.
Okay,
so what should you do about that?
You know,
should,
you know,
the tyrannical element is a real and
it's corrupt and blind and so to the
degree that you identify with that,
well then you're tyrannical and corrupt
and blind.
But by the same token,
you're the fortunate beneficiary of tens
of thousands of years of cultural and
technological evolution.
And it seems to me that an effort,
it seems to me that,
you know,
you should be at least appropriately
grateful for that.
And so then you're in a real position
because you have to be grateful and
happy for the thing that tyrannizing
controls you.
Well,
okay,
that's not an easy thing to figure out
because those things seem to conflict.
So what exactly should your relationship
to culture be?
Well,
I think there are myths that describe
that quite directly and they take into
account the corruption,
you know,
it's not a whitewash.
It's like,
yes,
of course this thing is dead and blind
and corrupt obviously,
and you know,
it's,
it's foolishness and,
and willful
ignorance and willful blindness that
make it that way as well as things
merely getting old and falling apart.
So the fact that there's some level,
it's at the bottom of it is also true.
Should you flee from Matt?
Well,
that isn't what the myths say.
You know,
they say what you're supposed to do is
just like Pinocchio.
You're supposed to go to the bottom of
the ocean to the most monstrous possible
part and rescue your father.
And that's what you have to do before
you become an individual.
No,
and
I can't see how that can't be.
Right.
So in fact,
I think that that's what you're doing in
university.
If you're here for,
if you're actually getting a university
education,
what you're here to do is to sift
through the dad remnants of the past and
pull up what's vital that's so
sophisticated and complex that there's
no way you'd be able to think it up for
yourself.
But you know,
it requires us,
the discriminating agent.
You know,
if you read someone like nature or you
read someone like Freud,
there's lots to throw away.
It isn't what you throw away though.
It's what you keep that matters.
And to be a discriminating reader means
that you get rid of the dead matter and
you keep the goal and you build yourself
up a storehouse of the gold and then,
and then you can live in the world.
And when you know,
people often ask,
you know,
what's the purpose of getting a degree
in the humanities?
While the answer to that is that
if you're properly trained in the
humanities,
you know how to live now,
that's not the same as having a job and
you need to have a job,
but,
but you know,
knowing how to live is a more important
thing than having a job even though
having a job isn't important thing.
So,
and the reason for that is that if you
don't know how to live,
then things fall apart and that's not
good and they can really fall apart.
You know,
and part of the reason I think that this
became so,
so much of an obsession for me is that I
believe that we don't have the luxury
of.
We are narrowing.
We've become so powerful that the
consequence of our blindness will,
is reaching uncontrollable proportions.
If you're weak and stupid,
well,
you know,
there's only so much damage you can do,
but we're not weak.
Not at all.
We have unbelievable power at our
disposal now and a lot of weird things
are going to come down the pipes in the
next 10 years.
So
the more people that have their act
together,
the better because
then things will be tilted towards
everything lining up in a positive
direction rather than being tilted in
the other direction.
And that's important.
And I think people can make a very
powerful individual contribution to that
wherever you happen to be.
So
you know,
all of these myths always say the same
thing.
They say that the history,
the future of the world depends on
individual choice.
And I think that's,
I think that's literally true.
So then you might think,
well you better put yourself in a
position where you make wise choices
because if you don't,
we've already seen what happens.
We got a taste of it in the 20th
century,
so if you want some more of that,
you could certainly have it.
Okay.
So.